This is the height of idiocy, but it appears
that Republicans are using former NFL
quarterback Colin Kaepernick's image for a
fundraising email and that they've digitally
darkened his skin to make him look a blacker
in the ad.
This is the NRCC, which is the National Republican
congressional committee.
They sent out an email on Wednesday and it
was all about the American flag.
Who Do you stand with?
The Ad Asks Donald Trump and the Betsy Ross
flag or anti American flag Colin Kaepernick.
Before we even look at what they did to Kaepernick
skin.
I just want to remind you that this entire
flag controversy is so stupid.
I mean, it's really depressing that this flag
issue would even be an issue to fundraise
around and that the right even cares about
this.
That's a really sad commentary on our country.
Most of you probably already know and understand
that, but then we get to the skin color issue.
When you look side by side at the original
picture and the version of it that was used
in this Republican ad, you can see that Colin
Kaepernick skin clearly seems much darker
in the picture.
That's included in the ad in particular.
When you look at his forearm now, the NRCC
was asked about this, they are claiming it
was not darkened.
What I hate about this is that this is actually
not a new tactic, but that it appears to actually
work.
Okay.
This has been studied in the 2008 campaign.
The McCain campaign was also caught darkening
Barack Obama skin when they published attack
ads.
And there was a study done in 2015 which found
that darkening the skin of political opponents,
as stupid as it sounds to many of us actually
impacts the impressions of voters about the
candidates.
And this isn't just republicans who do it.
The Hillary Clinton campaign in 2008 was also
accused of darker darkening Barack Obama's
skin in ads.
So the underlying idea is that no matter who
you are, that's running, no matter who you're
running against, whether it's a democratic
woman, a Republican man, the idea is there.
There's an unconscious bias that is strongest
against the darkest people, a people with
the darkest skin tone.
And this is called colorism.
I mean, this is not a new concept.
So it seems that it's an effective thing to
do, shockingly enough.
So there's a few different things that should
make us, I guess I would say sad here.
It's sad that political candidates would do
this.
They do it and they do it because it's work
because it works.
And that's actually the saddest part for me.
And then the absolutely dumbest part of this
goes way beyond darkening Colin Kaepernick
skin.
It's the sad reality that people still care
about this stupid flag thing.
Kneeling during the national anthem is not
disrespect to our troops.
They fought and fight so that we retain freedom
of speech and expression.
It's not that they fight to limit our protests,
only two approved ones that Republican's like
that is not actually freedom of speech and
expression.
Kneeling during the national anthem is not
disrespect to the country.
It's respect for the country in wanting to
change it for the better.
That's what Colin Kaepernick was kneeling
for.
Now, you could disagree with cap or nick about
the degree to which his priorities should
be priorities in the country.
You could say, I simply don't think that Colin
Kaepernick's concerns actually rise to the
level that Colin Kaepernick believes they
should or do.
Okay.
Well, I, I disagree with you, but that's an
actual respectful and logical debate to have.
But the idea that the mere protest that Colin
Kaepernick participated in is somehow anti-American
or disrespectful to the flag or disrespectful
to our troops.
It's disgusting that that actually qualifies
as a valid talking point to much of the American
right wing.
The catalyst for all this, right kneeling
during the anthem shouldn't even rank as a
controversy.
And the fact that it has is the biggest indictment
of all on a huge portion of our American political
constituents and that's why we can't convince
them not to vote for Trump in November of
2020 I've said it before.
I will continue to say it.
We have to win despite them not with them
and we need to get non voters to vote because
people who believe that it's a real tragedy
that Colin Kaepernick knelt during the, or
kneeled during the national anthem.
We're not going
to be able to bring them
to our side.